hi welcome to part 5 of game theory in
breaking bad
the background of the scene is that
jesse
has tried to confront the people
that ripped off one of his dealers
in a series of events jesse bungles the
operation and he's almo he's held at
gunpoint
but he luckily escapes when one of the
drug addicts takes out the other in a
fit of rage
jesse is an absolute wreck after this
he's witnessed the murder of someone he
feels that life isn't valuable and he's
trying to consult he consoles himself by
taking drugs
he thinks the entire thing is over and
he doesn't want to do anything more
walt comes in
and he explains why the situation
actually worked out to their advantage
here's the clip
the point of the scene
is to demonstrate the power of
reputation
and that the concepts of breakage and
blowfish
are complementary
when jesse was being stolen from when he
had breakage
the problem is that one robbery can
inspire others
and the rep the lesson there is that if
others think you are weak then that
itself is a weakness they will try and
test you
you have to put more effort to defending
yourself
on the flip side
is the advantage of being a blowfish
you appear to be tougher than you are
and no one can really tell that
so
the lesson here
is that if others think you are strong
then that itself is a strength
so jesse
should not feel uh
he should actually feel very happy
about what happened and walt explains
that he's a blowfish
he doesn't have to actually create this
reputation
someone has done that for him
i want to thank you for watching this
five part series on game theory and
breaking bad
there are many many more examples of
game theory in the show i just wanted to
highlight five of the examples to get
you started
and i also want to make an interesting
connection
in the show walt is a chemistry teacher
and his job is to be familiar with the
actions and reactions between chemicals
but there is a corresponding point which
is that wall is also a game theorist and
shows that he can calculate the actions
reactions and counter reactions between
people
thanks for watching this series please
subscribe to my channel and you can
catch me on my blog mindyourdecisions or
on twitter at preshtalwalker